something else that's changed with you
recently which I've been very very
enjoying watching happen I'm wearing
more clothes on my Instagram pictures
that's been nice for me personally as
well yes don't lie but your relationship
with alcohol Oh yeah talk to me about
your relationship with alcohol and how
it's changed yeah so I um I pretty much
barely drink anymore
um I used to be I guess that's because
of the whole British culture
I actually drink numerous times per week
particularly when I was growing up
University then even throughout my 20s I
was very much into my fitness but at the
same time there was always at least one
extremely heavy Blowout at the weekend
and then um it just carried on like even
I think when I was when I was
the just before no 29 at the first
experiment where I went sober for six
months
and that taught me a lot because I was
put in situations where I would normally
drink and because I was doing this
challenge I wasn't allowed to drink and
I think that was the first time that I
was in situations where
uh usually I would be drunk and like in
a relaxed State whatever it might be but
this time like I was sober I was doing
something which I would never do and I
actually realized it wasn't that hard to
do and actually quite liked it
and I think I just
life is this short and I can't afford to
have days wasting away feeling sorry for
myself being
aggressively hungover
which at the age I'm at now it was a
pretty aggressive yeah yeah yeah yeah
but what what I'll do now is I will
I will still drink
but it usually tends to be when I have
done
achieved something or I've got the job
done and
I can celebrate it's like okay you've
achieved this let's go out let's
celebrate have a drink if you want to
have a drink
once that's over then it's back to the
Grind again what else have you learned
from your time going sober obviously the
reason for doing it is that you don't
want to waste your days so much but what
else have you learned I actually really
enjoy my reality being sober
um
I actually don't really like the feeling
of being drunk anymore
I think now I'm at a point where I feel
like I'm very much in control I like
that I really like the person who I am
now when I'm sober I can I'm extremely a
lot more confident now I can have
conversations with anyone I can charm
people I can you know have a laugh I can
have a dance I can do it whatever I need
to do but I can do it sober and there's
actually no real need for me to drink
and when I do drink I realize actually
I start to get a little bit sloppy with
my words I say things which I wouldn't
normally say
might potentially regret and then
there's parts of the night all
conversation which I won't remember and
then I wake up feeling like absolute
trash
spend a lot of money as well out here on
alcohol which is usually just not wise
so it's uh
when I compare the positives to the
negatives there's actually very few
positives yeah
so this I mean you know this is
something I don't know I'm thinking now
like what so why did I dream that's the
question I had on the tip of my tongue
like you've you've laid out this balance
sheet of positives and negatives
why did either of us and this is both of
our upbringings right you know our
formative years in Newcastle and then
both of us stuck about once we finished
our degrees
going out drinking trabs
you know you can get absolutely
annihilated for like 10 pounds correct
yeah so again for the people that don't
know when we were at Uni could have got
three travel vodka mixers for a fiver
and you would usually get a free Jager
bomb with each of them so that's nine
shots of vodka plus three shots of
Jaeger for a fiver and the way that it
would work is you couldn't carry all of
them back you would have to pour all of
the Jaegers in together drink that drink
one of the trebs and then carry two back
um
so what I'm thinking is why is it
that
we ever saw it as something that not
only we would do we would willingly do
we would repeatedly do two nights a week
throughout all of uni
why I think
from thinking back when I was at
University I actually don't re now that
I recall I don't know anybody that
didn't drink I feel like every single
person drank yup and if there was anyone
that didn't drink they were just
they will wait you wouldn't hang out
with them but they weren't a part of the
social group yeah they weren't part of
the Social Circle
um I definitely remember drinking a lot
just feel more comfortable to reduce the
anxiety me too
um
yeah because especially when you're
having you're in uh a club the music's
really loud there's lights everywhere
there's people everywhere talking it's
really overwhelming
so the alcohol would numb that and then
you would feel more comfortable just to
interject that think about the modern
world
but this 2023 version of the world
someone would say that if that was a
challenge that you were coming up
against that that's because you're like
a blue pill beater simp guy who hasn't
worked on his masculine Essence and
stuff and I think that just to bring it
back to what we spoke about earlier on
about like why young guys struggling
specifically now
this expectation again that you should
have your [__] together you go really I
didn't yeah I didn't I absolutely drank
so I had confidence to speak to girls I
remember I used to have this I had this
uh like pink polo shirt and pair of
jeans and one night I pulled because
like and I was adamant that it was
because of this particular outfit I'm
like oh that's like that's the one and I
was so drunk that I could barely
remember what had happened during the
night and you think
what like what how
that's that's compensating for the fact
that it's
just a really highly stimulating pretty
anxiety-inducing environment
I think it it would probably make more
sense just to not go out
but that was that was like the biggest
part of university was going up
particularly Newcastle correct and that
was like the reason why I choose I chose
is that correct yeah so
yeah I don't know I guess at that age
you really don't have much
responsibility like I think back to
University
I mean I just
he obviously needs to get the bare
minimum done you have to do a bit of
studying you didn't have a job you're
just living off the student loan you
just haven't because you laugh yeah you
might so if you did wake up hungover
then
so I wasn't didn't really spend the
spend the day watching the Rugby World
Cup or whatever was going on the Six
Nations or some other thing on movies in
the in the common room and then get back
to it yeah I am
so I again I get that but I think
the number of people that drink the
number of young people that are choosing
to go low and no alcohol Lifestyles
massively increasing yeah I'd love to
say that this is Downstream from a trend
that I kicked off but I think it's
bigger than that and
I do I I can't work out what's going on
there I wonder whether
I think it's more it's just accepted now
I think it was really not acceptable
back in the day unacceptable to not
drink yeah unacceptable whereas now it's
like okay yeah fair enough
maybe that I think there's a lot more
informative content out there which is
showing just how bad alcohol is like
humans than the his video about alcohol
listen to that and you're like I wanna
drink again yeah it's terrible
yeah it's really really I think more
people are waking up to the negative
side effects of drinking alcohol
um
but it's still
there's still a lot of people drinking I
still have a lot of friends who are
drinking yeah but I just don't give a
[__] if I'm gonna offend their feelings
I wonder whether part of it
comes to choosing first off choosing the
kind of events that you go to and then
secondly that that growing in confidence
because you're right if you're in a
banging loud student nightclub with 1500
sweaty freshers and The Killers Mr
Brightside playing at ear bleeding
levels which is like beards spill on
your face correct you're that's not the
place for you to what advantage do you
have in being able to have a better
conversation that you almost need to
drink to be able to cope with the
environment that you're in to be able to
make it good and this is the thing that
I've been saying for like seven years
like if you need to drink in order to be
able to enjoy your night out you're
choosing the wrong nights out like what
you're saying is that the experience
that you're going on is so bad that you
have to anesthetize yourself you have to
numb yourself to the experience yo what
I was like saying I'm going to go and do
this push I'm going to go stick needles
through the skin on the back of my hand
but I'll take some painkillers it
doesn't hurt so much yeah hang on a
second as you grow up you start to do
different sorts of events you'll go for
dinner more you'll go to quieter venues
you'll go to somewhere where there's
live music where you can have a
conversation and that is that sort of
enjoyment is facilitated more by being
sober uh so I wonder whether it's a
byproduct of
kind of events that young people
typically attend I wonder whether Darren
my business partner is still doing all
the voodoo in the UK I wonder whether he
needs to I know do coffee and cocktail
hour at five o'clock in the afternoon or
something I don't know I think that's as
well when you're in an environment where
everybody else is drunk like that is
that's full on when you're sober and
you're just looking at people yeah
oh that's it's heavy like I'd I feel
like if I'm in an environment where
everybody's drunk
I almost need to be drunk just to deal
with it tolerate it correct yeah what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]